yes we're back playing subnautica I'm so
excited
I've been holding myself inside how you
say it holding yourself to play this on
my own spare time because I don't know
it's a really fun I really want to play
this if you missed out on my episode we
met a new friend mr. block isn't that
right mr. block
how do I play the game let's see if I
remember yes yes okay so I need water
I read you guys comment and stuff I know
how to do stuff look at that oh Jesus
what was that I'm sure it was fine
okay so I need these I think do I need
you I know I don't know I got it anyway
is it this that I need yes bladder fish
it goes peepee peepee oh yeah we crashed
with that spaceship that's what happened
and big planet thing smaller planet
thing and home here yes god damn about a
plane but it's so cool though this game
is so cool I can't believe I never
played it okay so now we can yes this is
water from the bladder fish what how and
we can disinfect it with bleach
do I have bleach oh God bleach Coral
tube sample how do I make that I'm gonna
have to cook mr. our friend he's dead
now sorry not my fault what else can we
make radiation suit yes that's what the
guy in the store told me that was
watching my series I need to make a
radiation suit air bladder yeah why not
I'll make an air bladder we all have one
MRI gamers sorry I need bleach
I need bleach right now so I need to
stab the plates got it all right we can
do this I'm not gonna die from water in
water that's just stupid
all right it's not a coral plate I think
that's coral play all right so we're
gonna stab you right now why can't I
stab it it says in the video tutorial
yes I think I did it I think I did it
take it take it take it where do you go
oh my god I lost them alright fine I'll
stab you
oh I got it I got it I got I got I got a
guy I'm not gonna dive god I don't not
like the sounds of this game not on I
don't know ah okay we're gonna live
gamers bleach bleach some time I needed
to I got that coral tube sample are you
high table coral set non-vegetarian I'll
drink it anyway okay okay okay all right
there's too much to do in this game I
can't keep up I cook my friends I cook
my friends I don't care I eat them
radiation suit we need so many things I
got so many things I'll get used to it
coral turd sample I'm the fishy thing
all right core to Seiberling the fishy
thing got it oh and a battery that's why
I came up really oh god the smack see oh
it's these if these tables you oh I'm
sorry am I not doing it
hello I'm sorry am I not doing it
perfectly why won't you die
hey stop stop
I need these let me pluck they let me
pluck you let me pluck you let me pluck
you oh it's these I need to pluck these
hey little buddy mine
okay surely this is say surely this is
what I mean
giant coral - yes yes yeah more MORE
yeah I'm killing it
freaky coral tube a meter is full that's
fine that's fine
daijoubu this where's my table oh it's
right there
excellent killing the game killing the
game gamers all right now we can drink
bleach finally delicious to drink to
drink yeah yeah be quite a woman I drink
this slurp that was some good slurping I
feel like we should make more though I
want more more bleach oh yeah all right
I think we're good on bleach what do you
guys think I think we're good on bleach
I know this is painful but I think we're
gonna have to ditch some of the
buttholes cuz I don't I don't think we
need that many of it I don't really know
why I picked up that many to begin with
alright it's a new day where I look at
this look at this is so pretty
what is this blop blop blop I need more
storage I don't need a radiation soon
fine I'll make the radiation soon
because I actually know how to make it
alright so I think it's over here yes
yes yes yes yes
quiet quiet fishes don't speak everyone
knows this I think we just cut these I
think we just cut these yes dead you're
dead you're dead
I'm already full on inventory or you get
other massive do fine I'll swim back
don't care
whoa what there was a dude that reminds
me legit oh my god that's scared from
actually when I was in the Caribbean
when I was like 14 I had one of my most
traumatic where's this freaking tub
anyway I had one of my most true that is
a flying fish why are they flying I
pluck you oh I killed him sorry I didn't
mean to do that I had one of my most
traumatic experiences ever because we
were fated we were snorkeling in this
amazing water kind of like this
obviously not alien fishes and stuff but
it was like unreal for a Swedish person
at least who's done a lot of snorkeling
in my day I was still amazed by all the
fishies hey I can make the fiber now to
make the radiation suit does it make two
of them or does it make one at them I
think it made one of them dang it
so I was fishy to me she fishing as you
do as a Swedish but I put the egg in
there looking at the fish chest it was
all relaxing it was all nice it was
wonderful it was so cool you could like
swim up to fish and be like hey do that
but then all the sudden all the fish is
just boom and I was like oh that's weird
and I'm like out pretty far as well like
this it was basically like this you see
all the fishes just fly away and I'm
like alright strange guest fishes do
that no they don't
in out of nowhere comes to giant fish
with teeth sticking out like in my
peripheral where do you come from
[Laughter]
at least I can pause in the game because
what happened was I I saw it and I was
so scared I threw myself up on the beach
like wow I thought it was a shark it
wasn't a shark it was a fish like this
like I think it was a barracuda or
something it still scared me clearly
nothing has changed I'm 30 years old
you're dead you're dead I'm gonna kill
you now I faced my fears I faced my
fears I faced my fears I / it I - it
yeah run away [ __ ] run away alright
cool the light I got to relive that
experience I'm never telling a story of
my childhood ever again lesson learned
right now we have radiation stood maybe
they will not mess with us anymore can I
make it I should be able to lead do I
have a lead I do have leave nice lucky
me huh lucky day aren't I lucky now make
the suit now it's it's mine okay cool
so I have a lead helmet and oh I got all
this stuff cool so what's next on the
list for me to make I think it's the
repair gun what the hell is that
yeah dude can you know it oh dude I was
trying to kill it the other thing the
suicide fish is like in these caves I
think where are you mr. fishy
I swim through this for no reason at all
this music is making me hype though I
like this I like this I guess we can
make another battery then I need them
but holes for the battery so I do need
them for something luckily I just tossed
them down here caves sulfur I don't I'm
not sure how to find the keg sulfur
it's the explosion fish it would make
sense that they have a sulfur I just
don't remember where I saw them all
right now we have a fresh battery to
cure egg haha what you gonna do how are
you gonna do I take your egg Oh
what that is it made boom-boom yeah all
right so where is the things from it
could it be from here huh see what so
far we found it but I'm full
I want more where where are you where
you hurt me all right let's find its
source where did they come from
dang it there's so much to take in and
Carib breathe baby 3 that down the go
alright say wasn't here I'll find it
I'll find it this is the one and then
there was another one there phone it yes
[Applause]
George or have I told you guys I finally
watched Jojo I know I said watch Joe I
watched Jojo before watch mojo oh and
partly I can use fuel as well to go
faster I guess I'll say that for
emergency i watch season 1 and why did
no one tell me that season 2 is like 10
times better it's so good I could have
been part of so many memes now I was
just cringy to reference Joe new because
everyone does it like season 1 wasn't
bad but it wasn't like as good as
everyone said it was alright so now we
can make the repair tour no we can't we
also need the silicone rubber which we
get from there yeah the balls the ball
sack I'm always full of stuff always I
don't need that many balls I'm gonna be
honest guys all right well we know where
to get the last bit so let's just do
that
bye butthole I'll save two for good luck
always save to buttholes for good luck
hey you freak off freak off I will kill
you I will murder you I will murder you
that's death all right what are you fine
here
yeah mine yeah that's right mine
alright found it these are the ones
already full oh my god they take so much
space oh god I dropped these my friends
I hope I just need two of them God Danny
I'm gonna be annoyed so apparently you
can build out your base and stuff like
that you can make like this you can make
submarines as well dude can you Frick
off I hate you so much
don't touch it don't touch it let go got
it
stinky Steve's trying to know much stuff
dude alright we almost have there repair
two very close silicon 2x okay perfect
we got the sillies no I did not mean to
click this what did I do
Oh God that I mess up my repair tool I
did because I need titanium which I have
because I am tied there it is I'm not
gonna sing that song cause I'll get
copyrighted but just imagine them the
most beautiful voice of all time repair
tool haters said I couldn't do it but I
did diddly do it elite now that we have
the repair tool should I make more
storage I feel like this is so dumb like
why am i how do I make storage I forgot
whoa it's all dark now and damn it's so
pretty
dude it's like it's hovering right in
front of my face what the hell are those
which can I fly in this game I bet you
can fly in this game all right I forgot
we had the repair tool we should
probably repair stuff ow why I do this
so whatever repair first this looks like
communication I don't know why I pretend
like I know okay
okay I did something all right I got
some data bank what else I repair I
repair radio oh great great
thank you thank you what oh I'm so glad
I did that
oh I see it so I use the bladder to kind
of make myself a rise to the surface
quicker that's cool I'm getting the hang
of the game I'm not sure what the next
step is you know what maybe now it's a
good time to go to the [ __ ] right it's
right there
I haven't done it let's go I'm ready as
I'll ever be
who knows what we'll find on the way as
well right there's mr. boomy the boomer
I need you I need you for what there I
need you for what there brick got you he
heard me and oh god these are so creepy
should I stab it and see what happens
maybe I can harvest his eggs oh maybe I
should scan him oh my god I got to be
close all right let's get the eggs your
eggs are mine cool that guy worked all
right let's get the peepee okay we're
almost at the ship what's the worst
thing that can happen just another day
in the ocean swimming swims in swim
swimming so much fun doing good gamers
do you stay away from me you stay away I
hurt you I heard that anything that
doesn't stay away from me oh there's two
of them fight to that coward you to you
to you to you to come at me I've been
studying that Chinese Swedish martial
arts for very long time eh all right
metal salvage ooh hello all right it's
clear
that's biggest Meggie oh I like this
engine fragment okay maybe later we need
that hey can I walk here yeah I made it
look at me Mom
amazing I'm flipping what the hell is
that
that's illegal fishes don't do that stop
it stop it that's right I thought dummy
all right how do I get in
where's the entrance I'm full so I might
as well go back what is this titanium
they dine them as my own else watch the
[ __ ] stop it
all right we're cool the spooky thing
about fishes is you don't really hear
them sneak up on you because fishes
don't generally make sounds which I
don't like
it makes it look make it like they can
just come at any moment you know you
just got to be ready for it all right
we're good
I want a harpoon I want a spear I want
something to shoot the fish with why not
okay okay possible dick attitude are
there other people like me is that is
that what they've said you really don't
need to eat a lot in this game which
makes me happy because then I can eat a
little habitat be out there so I need
this this is the next thing I need and I
chop it and I chop chop chop chop chop
chop a chip shop I plug plug plug and I
chef chef chef a fishy like a num num
num I built that base and what is that
what yeah I don't have time to say
people that's not my job so now I can
make computer ship ship ship ship and
the ship ship ship a make computer ship
ship ship
nice advanced wiring kit just need one
more silver or which I don't know where
I got it from
maybe I can put some stuff in this yeah
I can all right I'll put these it's
something I guess we have to go and save
the people it's fine
let's go gamers I say people okay let's
find silver on the way that would be
really epic oh god it's in here I don't
like this area I don't like this area Oh
found it mr. three are there dead oh god
they're dead all right let's take their
stuff I wonder what they have silver
please Oh possibly the dick attitude
it's impossible for me to find this even
without the blueprint god dang it
as long as there's no octopus shut up
shut the or fight me then fight me then
I ain't afraid of some fishy go back to
fish land which is here but whatever
alright let's go
I got a PD it yeah yeah yeah that's what
I thought
that's what I thought that's what oh you
write your friend now then you did once
I get harpoons I will kill you also
ill so hard I need this I need the
wiring kit so I can build stuff for my
base I need it so gosh nanban that I
swore I can't believe it you know how I
said hey let's harvest the eggs and
you're you were all like oh he's crazy
god dammit I can't see anything
those big things harvest sex they have
the silver they have it are you serious
oh god I don't like being out at night I
wish I could sleep like Minecraft you
know I especially don't like harvesting
giant alien water monsters at night
that's not that's not top of my list of
things I want to do there they are
this is it this is what I need barnacles
are you kidding me okay okay drop
something so they dropped those ow you
hurt Swedish man not cool what the hell
is this all right it's hurting me I
don't know how it's hurting me I guess
they don't like me harvesting them well
that's too bad
Taylor Swift I will harvest your eggs
where'd you go something is attacking me
oh it's those things they're shooting me
they got defenses is that Alright I
think a harvest all I can from that one
where's your friend there is what are
you cool ah yes
give me the silver come on come on come
on come on it's copper every time did
someone lucky come on dang it silver
have you heard of it
silver silver dang it stop it silver
silver silver silver silver useless
you're absolutely useless do you know
this do you know this do you have you
heard about this do you know how useless
you're and disgusting as well have I
told ya no one likes you you have no
friends there has to be more of them I
will find them it's a silver salt which
is what I am when I can't find silver Oh
God
deploy that did not do anything what the
hell I was ready to fly but the hell did
that do that he did nothing
are you kidding me let go of that let go
that you're embarrassing me
you cannot be serious dude can you make
a sound I in this game that'd be awesome
so one of my favorite things before you
jump in the water and Street then you
you jump in the sound huh well look
they're crashing into each other because
they're dumb you're dumb you have no
brain your brain is filled with gunk
gunk eNOS all right come on I feel like
the first silver I found was in a box so
maybe we should just keep searching
boxes all right all right you want to
fight you wanna fight because I don't I
don't I changed my mind
all right let's use the thing all we
charges it charges okay I only wish
someone told me that hey dancing dancing
dancing dancing dancing doesn't dance
and dance and dance and dance and dance
and doesn't what's that that's another
pod
I found one just by looking around ok
gamer ooh
ultra glide okay is that the cave that
we're talking about that leads to a new
biome let's explore it really quick
maybe we find silver in there look at
this there's got to be silver here mean
it gotta be zillion me all silver dang
it
silver dang it Stuart whoa whoa silver
all right I'm done I just need silver I
don't think that's too much to ask
I got gold yes yes yes I got it
oh no I got gold but I my inventory full
drop assault I don't know
ow ow ow back up back up backing up
backing up
ah oh I'm up eggs alright final eggs for
the trip they got nothing you useless do
you understand how useless you are how
bad you are disgusting you are how big
you are
I don't like you who you are all right
we got a gamer's we break in got it
flip flop flip flop flip flop flip flop
flip flop there it is and then I can
make an advanced wiring kit why would I
do that advanced construction okay I
don't know what I need that is advanced
right now I need a habitat bill there
it's mine yep good good because I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna do it this is it
dude this looks like my shaver so I can
deconstruct things now we can do these
things
yes base attached air pumps oxygen for
power habitat do
attach pipe work alright where do we put
the locker what maybe we need to be out
excuse me how do I build in this game I
don't I understand I was alright let's
listen to the radio we already find how
much sex we already found number six
don't care but you died he's all
terrorists ships they run low on engine
grease send an SOS help what I have BAM
I'm out on the far side of the system
it's gonna take more than
to reach your position do you still need
our assistance yes yes yes
damn charters gonna have us blowing our
credits running errands for all Terra
Bing being being being being being being
being being being being being being
being being being yeah man man dude all
right that solved all my problems are
you gonna attack me cuz I will kill you
come at me come at me your [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you belong at [ __ ] land isn't it
really dangerous in real life to ascend
super quickly when you're in underwater
you can get like water sickness or
something or diving sickness I don't
know what it's called I don't know
anything I don't even know why I speak
all I need is materials for my little
house I just want to build a house I
freakin flew up it's so satisfying it
feels like a dungeon crawler I almost
said I don't know like you go down you
get all the stuff and then you feel good
that you got all this stuff when you go
ahead back home if only you could feel
so productive in real life if only yeah
hey I found gold what's up what do you
do today I'll play video games cringe I
don't think I ever explored this area
don't shoot me uh-huh uh-huh that's the
song yeah there's nothing really here
all right time to swing back all right
we're back and look how much stuff I
have got damn I'm gonna end that episode
there if you guys enjoy this series I
want to support it a great way to do it
is smash like subscribe hit Bell button
and I see you guys next time thanks for
watching bye bye
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course
pixal aims is a creature collecting game
I'm the primary shareholder over a
Brazilian players have downloaded and
it's got a perfect score
it's safe to say it's the most popular
game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it deal with
[Music]